le matin c'est dur titre cette nouvelle
intro et sponsorisé par vous même
puisque c'est vous qui décidez donné un
trou dans les commentaires n'hésitez pas
pour la semaine prochaine
aujourd'hui nous allons réserver un pas
oui est-ce que tu savais qu'il y avait
un mec tu es tu à paris très proche mans
rennes je voulais quelque chose de très
important et le dire je stresse était au
courant il ya un mec qui accueillait un
casse tête pour toi qui l'a créé un
casse tête pour toi incroyable la holy
ghost mais c'est fou mais oui mais
comment tu veux que je sache sa
formation saxo là je te le dis d'accord
elle genre un vrai casse tête
voilà un vrai casse-tête genre un truc
en bois un peu comme ce genre de choses
là j'en bois et genre un peu carré
plutôt un peu comme celle ci boîte
carrée exactement qu'avec un mais
comment je peux faire du coup pour la
voir c'est pour ça que c'est beaucoup
parce que moi j'aimerais bien la faire
et du coup c'est celle ci en fait ah bah
ouais c'est celle du coup j'ai calé à
résoudre aujourd'hui
ouais ok mais trop cool bon heureusement
que cela c'est sûr je me le dit souvent
du coup il est aujourd'hui c'est pas un
casse tête non mon bon monsieur c'est
pas deux casse-tête non à bonn madame
ses deux casquettes on va aussi c'est
exactement ça de casse têtes en bois de
boîtes qui va falloir résoudre la
fameuse holly boxe que j'ai reçu très
récemment par mr wolf on y reviendra
tout à l'heure je les mets sur le côté
pour le moment et on va commencer par
cette caste est là aussi qui est une
boîte que j'ai trouvé par hasard aussi
sur amazon faire le lien de tous les cas
cet homme à chaque fois tu es dans la
description sauf celui ci parce qu'il
est unique et petit rappel la tournée du
spectacle continue je suis demain à
lausanne je suis du 22 au 24 novembre à
mulhouse le 2 décembre à enghien le 13
décembre sélestat et toutes les autres
villes de garer dans la description
alors oui se gaspille c'était vraiment
entraînant sur amazon le choix que
j'avais trouvé donc je l'avais acheté il
n'était pas extrêmement cher c'est une
boîte secrète y avait pas de niveau
particulier et je n'ai pas encore
tripatouiller le seul truc c'est que là
sans le toucher vraiment on voit qu'ici
ça bouge
de manière extrêmement nettes ici non
mais c'est en fait l'ensemble des rouges
un tout petit peu vous faire voir comme
ça peut-être avec la caméra du dessus on
voit que ça bouge
je sais pas si ça demande à se lever ou
à se lever d'un cent soit glissé comme
ça dans ce sens je sais pas trop et ma
foi il n'y a rien de spécial à paimpol
de montchat ok donc comme il ya que
saddam horrible donc je sens qu'il n'est
pas très complexe insu l'un est ce que
je peux le tourner à fond d'accord si je
tends la main il se passe quoi alors
quand je tourne à fond saveurs où il
fasse l'autre là y'a plus de jeux de du
tout du coup ça doit libérer quelque
chose à l'intérieur j'imagine ses
ingénieurs les casse têtes en moi je
sais pas comment les mecs pensent à
faire ça
d'accord las quand je suis dans cette
position j'ai encore plus d'ouverture
que au départ j'en ai carrément j'ai une
grosse ouverture mais fixe persane eux
ça ne bouge ça bouge
ok alors j'ai pu le pousser encore un
peu plus comme ça et j'ai dit d'accord
en fait voilà
heureusement qu'il y avait ça n'a
derrière parce que sinon je ne sais pas
de ce que ok pas très dur mais alors un
temps est-ce que j'ai bien tout comprend
pas ce que je suis capable de le refaire
donc là j'ai la boite tourner ça comme
ça et j'ai oui voilà
en fait quand je tiens là ça marche pas
ah c'est comment qu'est ce que j'ai fait
d'accord il faut la mettre sur le côté
il faut juste km sur le moteur encore
bon bout d'une boîte facile en même
temps ont vu le prix qu'elle m'a coûté
ça me donne pas qu'elle soit assez
simple des ventes non je dirais passage
que d'accord avec vous mais je me
doutais quand même que l c'est pas hyper
hard à avoir un à un les reason
gentleman vous avez été plus de 1000 par
jour à me dire que mr vol tu m'avais
construit un casse tête alors que j'ai
commenté sa vidéo et que sa top com et
que je le sais et j'en ai parlé dans
l'historie sur un star mais c'est pas
grave mais je suis persuadé qu'une fois
que cette bise de strass sortie je
continuerai quand même à recevoir des
messages pour m'informer que mr west
dans certaines vidéos pour toi mais ne
le regarde pas en danger parce que sinon
tu peux être là c'est super cool mr holt
je trouve ton taf
incroyable je connaissais la chaîne
depuis que doc seven à béton saluer
internet il ya longtemps et c'est même
doc qui le jour de la sortie immédiate a
dit ce qu'il a fait et où je n'avais pas
encore vu et après jeu après jeu l'est
bien bien bien sûr qu'elle était sorti
la boîte parce que vraiment j'ai
beaucoup trop reçu le message et je te
déteste pour ça j'en reçois tous les
jours encore dans une quantité aléatoire
entre 30 et 100 tout réseau mail
confondues commentaires youtube je les
ai même pas compter ce que je trouve
déjà ou faux c'est la propreté du
trickster que la g1
jackass tête unique réalisé que pour moi
mais il est extrêmement bien fait mais
je sais pas si tu as déjà vu ces vidéos
pas loïc la parcelle où tu m'a prévenu
du coup non regarde parce que le montage
est hyper stylé et sa colère de fou quoi
tu vois mais la qualité ces vidéos en
plus c'est de ces projets ils sont ils
sont ils sont juste dingue vous avez un
lien dans la description vers la chaîne
de mr hall et du coup c'est parti là
déjà pour la phase d'exploration je
crois bien cogner
excuse moi pour les cheveux loïc mais je
voulais voir si c'était vraiment
pyrogravés qui sait avec des pyrograveur
tout cas je sais pas c'est ça mais c'est
très bien fait ok là il ya un petit peu
de jeu c'est ça gigote un peu là je peux
clairement appuyé par contre à
d'ailleurs c'est rollier parce que ça
fait bouger l'autre bout pas combien
d'autres bruyants plus à l'intérieur
écoutez bien vous allez bruit des
travaux de la rue en même temps ça ça
doit juste tenir un ensemble de bons
c'est comment ça marche bon ça c'est un
tiroir et on se souvient rien ok donc
tout se passe avec ça
[Musique]
là je ne peux pas là je peux enfoncé mon
doigt titre là je bats je peux encore
d'ailleurs alors que là je peux plus et
là je peux d'accord ok donc on est à peu
près comme dans le système de cette
boîte
il ya un truc ou faut retourner la boîte
donc une fois qu'on l'a retourné c'est
bien c'est bien vêtements pour appuyer
mais je sais pas ce qu'on peut faire
d'autre
est-ce qu'on peut encore appuyer plus
après
je me dis que c'est se trouve avec un
autre mouvement peut-être que je peux
encore appuyé profonde et moi et safege
cook
tu vois où page cook jeu tout va bien je
vois qu en détresse à tes shsh look
moi je vais remis à l'endroit ça bloque
pas c'est ainsi la saru voilà je crois
que ça vient titres aaa
ça va j'ai peur d'avoir pété c'est quoi
sa démence a même passé un trombone
s'appelait lui que c'est un trombone
c'est pas une très bonne
c'est comme pour les vis et les boulons
est ce que tu peux nous prouver avec un
petit panneau rapide que tu as compris
ce qu'était un vice ou nice un vin rouge
on est à un écrou ou une écrou bien sûr
le voici
et ben voilà
là on voit que c'est bien plus clair
courtois ah oui il ya un petit aimant
bien sûr mois chez le roi pour découvrir
les eaux sont les aimants avec des
trombones donc c'est comme ça que ça ce
n'est que ça te plaît ici à la vache
chef café de thym mettre mon doigt titre
je sais pas si on voit là le clou pas si
je fais ça c'est énorme
ok du coup ça veut dire n'appuie surtout
pas ici ou en tout cas pas avec ton
doigt parce que sinon ça peut faire très
mal
mais comme j'ai une pièce qui s'est
libéré et qui a quand même une marque de
trous de cloud ici ce qui veut dire que
quelqu'un a déjà appuyé dessus avec et
bien je vais exactement je ne sais pas
si c'est un indice icc a été voulue
aussi juste il a testé sa boîte mail il
ya vraiment un petit pique aux deux
clous ici donc je pense qu'il a
exactement positionner ici comme ça et
alors le tiroir il est là ah oui
d'accord le tiroir est même clairement
monté à l'envers là ok ok donc gros
ressort est tous très ingénieux par
contre je ne sais pas comment il a fait
pour que dans un sens on puisse appuyer
et dans l'autre sens on ne puisse pas
appuyer
c'est un mystère pour moi ce genre de
mécanisme
ok on va au moins lire ça salut merci
d'avoir accepté de recevoir ma boîte tu
plaisantes merci à toi c'est trop cool
j'espère donc tu l'a pas ouverte un
train de seconde alors trente secondes
non en même temps sans parler un peu
concentré j'ai été encore plus rapide
mais assez vite en sinon je tends refait
une autre plus complexe bah je suis
chaud mais tu m'envoies un message à moi
pour me dire qu'elle est prête plutôt
que n'en parle plus plus je mens pas et
maintenant tu peux aller voir la vidéo
en entier sur ma chaîne tu pourras voir
comment j'ai fabriqué la boîte
excellent donc c'est à dire que dans sa
vidéo on va comprendre comment marche
tous les mécanismes et et et comment il
a fait tout ça à 15 ans il se trouve
c'est avec ça d'ailleurs que qu'on a
poussé l'ensemble encore un puisse merci
ça c'est quoi de petits autocollants de
sa chaîne comme ça on peut passer un
petit badge carrément ok d'accord on a
des gaullistes chez mr bah je trouve ça
super balansun c'est la première fois
qu'on me fait un cadeau aussi
personnalisé j'avais une boîte un jour
mais c'était plus une boîte énigmes la
juste ce casse tête là en mode comme les
boîtes que je suis en ce moment je
trouve ça hyper badass donc merci à toi
cette boîte je ne la ferai pas gagné
parce que je la garde pour moi
celle ci je vous la fais gagner sur
instagram comme d'habitude vous avez le
lire dans la description comme chaque
semaine parce que je place pour tout
stocker en gros c'est très simple vous
commentez sous cette photo là et après
je fais le tirage au sort le mardi donc
la veille du prochain casse tête et
voilà c'est une affaire rondement mené
c'était pas des boîtes très très
compliqué aujourd'hui j'avoue mais aussi
c'était c'était assez agréable car je
range et les autocollants ici je vous
rappelle que mes deux nouveaux projets
sont sortis à savoir la memory box qui
est vraiment ma méthode pour pouvoir
réussir à tout apprendre est également
mon énigmes qui permet quand même de
gagner travaille là dessus pendant plus
d'un an
cinq diamants d'une valeur de 5000 euros
voilà vous avez les liens aussi dans la
description ici vous avez la vidéo du
jeu 8 beatbox qu'on a fait avec la dream
team c'était c'est vraiment c'est un
concept de ouf c'est comme une console
de jeu mais c'est pas une console de
jeux regarder ça et ici le casse-tête de
la semaine dernière la pyramide
qui a failli me faire abandonner ce
métier a été chaude tu te souviens quand
même pensez à vous abonner l'ikea très
bientôt
mercredi prochain 6 heures ciao cooper o